hey guys how's it going uh so today we
are shooting for this show called star
trek we've actually been shooting it for
a while it's such a fun show and i'm so
excited so i'm hosting we have some
awesome judges tyler ward is one of the
judges it's basically
uh
i don't want to tell you guys too much
about it because you'll find out soon
i'm gonna go back inside francesca is
gonna do a little touch-up here and
we're gonna continue our fun shoot oh
there's i was just talking about you i
was like i have to go inside did i come
i had to get coffee
yeah i'm starting to fade it's been it's
been a long day it kind of has i'm
feeling very tired
oh look at you guys just getting some
makeup done
are you making fun of our selfies is
that what you're looking at that's a
good one hey look you're in the vlog
i'm in the vlog am i nice to tyler hello
mr tyler i love your voice
i'm reading books guys tyler just said
he started reading books it was really
exciting asked me why why did you start
why did she start reading i know i
started reading books because i have to
grow the paper
so we're here today on star truck and
francesca just did my hair and my makeup
it was a while ago but i just started
vlogging so this is a
i don't know what i'm allowed to tell
them
this is what a film set looks like when
everyone's really hard at work hard work
yeah and don't get the guy sitting on
the floor
just don't keep it out of that before
we just got back from lunch well here's
the logo there's
yeah it's been really fun we've actually
had a we've been shooting for
this has been on for a while
it's all just kind of piecing itself
together we are just about wrapping up
today it's been so much fun i love
working with this crew everyone is so
nice and oh i'm just actually speaking
of i'm just saying everyone's so nice
and so much fun how's it going nice to
see you guys we had a fantastic time
with justine with tyler with adam with
everybody star trek rocks justine rocks
boom up top i can't wait to see the show
like i'm so excited because i only hear
like little tiny pieces oh sorry so i
only get to see
little little snacks of it let's see if
you can find tyler because i'm actually
right are you leaving i'm just chilling
i'm right making it do you want to be in
my video yeah hi say hi hi say hi i'm
tyler this is tyler i'm recording right
now what are you recording i am
recording a cover song with moment what
is it that's just taylor swift just
dropped her new track um i love it yeah
i love it so much um when are we gonna
do a song together do you wanna do it
with me as soon as possible it sounds
like what song should we do guys let us
know
um so i think i'm i think i'm done now
do you want to tell us about star trek
and how excited you are because i'm
really excited i'm so incredibly excited
and so incredibly tired a very long shoe
good job it's been a long day but your
bow tie looks fantastic oh thank you
yeah it's spicy
nothing it's great
so how do you think today went you think
it was good i think it was amazing
actually better than i could have hoped
for yeah four guys are exactly the same
all the running backs
he's like a troublemaker i mean look at
him like we're supposed to be he's
supposed to be judging and he's
recording a cover song
like who are you okay it's like he can't
help himself
it's gotta get that exposure that's true
it's a good song i actually really like
it any running back in there you like
this version
okay well i'm gonna go home now i look
forward to uh you guys seeing this show
eventually so i just made it home and i
was so excited to post my tech tuesday
but it looks like tech tuesday might
have to be tech wednesday or tech
thursday it keeps giving me this error
it gave me this error this morning so
i'm probably gonna have to re-edit it
which is not gonna be fun
why you gotta be so rude
don't you know i gotta post
my movie i'll see you guys tomorrow
thanks for watching i'll be off on an
adventure with my sisters for the next
couple of days and i know that's the
only reason that you guys actually watch
my videos is so you'll be able to see
brie so stay tuned there'll be a few
minutes of brie
bye love you